La volta al món a peu, dia 247.
Acabo de fer check-out del meu hotel aquí a Bukhara.
Avui és dilluns 3 d'agost i són les 10 i 23.
Ahir vaig tenir, bueno, aquest cap de setmana he tingut una mica de crisi
perquè volia anar a Hiba, però no hi havia tren a Hiba.
No el trobava el tren a Hiba.
I dic, bueno, estarà ple, perquè es veu que el tren s'omple bastant ràpid aquí a Uzbekistan.
Llavors l'opció que havia llegit per internet era agafar un taxi compartit 6 hores
i si el trobava perquè estava descompartit, doncs s'omplen i quan s'omplen surt per 20 euros.
I bueno, ja estava disposat a fer això, però resulta que és que em vaig equivocar.
És que no hi ha tren directe des de Bukhara a Hiba.
He d'anar a una ciutat que està molt a prop de Hiba i des d'allà hi agafar un taxi o el que sigui.
Per tant, cap problema, he comprat el bitllet i d'aquí menys d'una hora
surt el tren ràpid, que és que compara...
Els temps, eh?
Taxi, 6 hores i pico.
Tren ràpid, menys de 3 hores.
D'acord, porto la motxilla molt carregada perquè tinc totes les postals que no vaig enviar,
perquè clar, era el cap de setmana.
I ara m'agradaria anar... Vaig una mica just de temps, eh?
Però m'agradaria anar a una oficina de correus primer,
comprar els segells o preguntar com a mínim com es fa el tema dels segells
i després ja agafar un taxi a l'estació de tren, que està molt lluny.
Està tipus a mitja hora de Bukhara, no està al centre, està molt a les afores.
Anar.
Què va, no em dóna temps. No, no.
Ni ho intento. No, és de pura massa.
Vaig a demanar un taxiar des d'aquí perquè entre que ve i tal,
encara arribaré tard i no, no és pla.
Uau, crec que no arribo, eh?
El tren és 11.14 i aquí fica que arribem a les 11.07
però es va cada cop retreçant més el temps d'arribada.
Així el perdo. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Va, tieto.
Rahmat, Rahmat, el tio, un crac.
Li he dit, sisplau, vés més ràpid que se m'escapa el tren.
I el tio no ha dit res i diu, ok.
I comença.
Però bé, eh? Sense jugar-se la vida ni res.
Perfecte. Són i cinc, queden nou minuts.
Aquí tenim l'estació de tren.
Arribo, arribo, arribo bé.
Doncs tenim ja el tren en moviment.
Veurem bastant de desert.
Em sembla que us va agradar bastant el vídeo de Teixquen.
Per mi és molt més fàcil fer els blocs jo parlant
que com el de Bocara, que és allò on la Déu a nof i tal
requereix més curro, aquest segon.
Per tant, bé, si us ha agradat així, el faré així.
Jo, al final, el que faig és, vas pels jocs, em sorprènc.
Són reaccions ja un, genuïnes, eh?
Però sí, sí, és com anar de tontet una mica.
Ostres, que guapo, això no m'ho esperava.
Però és així, eh?
I a Bocara, no ho vaig dir, però...
Hello.
Era així, era així.
Em vaig sentir molt privilegiat l'altre dia perquè em portessin a esmorzar a la classe Business.
Però avui també me l'han portat i estic a la classe Economy.
Per tant, és que el tren és genial i ja està.
Aquest tren de l'Uzbekistan.
A més, té gratis també.
D'acord, com encara tinc un parell d'hores o així,
vaig a fer postals.
He enganxat ja les adreces, però em fa falta posar l'edicatòria i tinc feina, tinc feina.
Puntual no.
Puntualíssim.
Un minut abans he arribat.
He aconseguit acabar totes les postals, això sí.
No he pogut menjar res, però ho he aconseguit.
Val? Ara taxi fins a Hiba.
Directament jo crec a l'oficina de correus, que em portin allà.
L'oficina de correus és un dels moments més càlids del dia.
Aquí està l'oficina de correus.
A veure si he de complir els segells o simplement donant les postals i pagant com a altres països funciona i així m'estalvio això.
Què és aquí?
Aquí he de trobar el mapa.
I have postcards to send.
How does it work?
Yes.
Parcel no, eh? Postcards.
A lot of postcards.
7 milions acabo de pagar per les postals.
7 milions.
Quan és això, Enric? Sembla molt.
Doncs no, no ho és.
Són de fet les postals més barates que hi ha.
De la volta al món a peu.
500 i escaig euros.
I això si li sumes el que m'han costat les postals, que era 120 euros.
Ostres, tu hem passat de les postals més cares a Georgia a les més barates d'aquí a Uzbekistan.
Que bé.
Encara me'n queden crec que unes 15 per enviar, però bueno, seran 15 euros més. Perfecte.
Molt bé, són les tres i pico, vaig cap a l'hotel.
Ah, bueno, i m'ha deixat pagant targeta, cosa que està molt bé perquè si no hagués hagut d'anar al caixer a treure.
I no he hagut de posar els segells.
Perfecte, tu, m'ha dit.
Ja t'ho franquejo jo.
Bueno, tot amb Google Translate, eh?
Normalment, encara que la gent no parlés d'anglès, en alguna oficina hi havia algú que sí que parlava anglès. Aquí no.
Aquí ha sigut amb Google Translate i no amb Uzbek.
Si no amb rus.
Suposo que amb Uzbek no funcionava bé, no ho sé, però ella mateixa ja m'ho posava en rus, eh?
De rus a anglès.
Anem a veure l'habitació de l'hotel.
Són les quatre i mitja.
Molt bé, no?
És un hotel nou, pel que he dit a les ressenyes.
Molt bé, tu.
Molt bé, mira-la.
La tele encara té precinto. Ah, no, està com enganxat.
Molt bé, tu, una passada.
Sabeu com m'ha costat això?
30. 30 euros, dos nits, esmorzar inclòs.
Molt bé, tu.
He dinat, també.
He menjat molt bé, molt bé.
I molt barat, també.
Una espècie de tomàquet molt bo.
La butxeta aquesta, buah, la butxeta aquesta està boníssima.
I els rotllets aquests, bueno, més normalets, però també molt bé.
Bueno, si veniu a Uzbekistan, molta gent ve a l'agost o al juliol perquè va de camí a Kirguistán,
que és el país que és interessant per anar a aquesta època de l'any,
perquè les muntanyes, doncs, pot fer senderisme a aquesta època de l'any en altitud, no?
Llavors aprofiten per passar per Uzbekistan, perquè està a prop i ja que estàs aquí està bé.
Però clar, aquesta època fa una calor brutal, seria una mala època per venir,
però bueno, si és l'única manera de venir, doncs està bé.
Però llavors el que fa la majoria, el que faig jo, és, jo durant el dia no surto.
De 12 a 6 o així estic a l'hotel.
A mi em va bé, perquè jo tinc bastanta feina a fer, editar vídeos i tal.
Si ets un turista normal, entre cometes, doncs home, són moltes hores del dia desperdiçades, no?
Però bueno, mira, així aprofites.
Val, jo ara vaig a editar i tal, tal, tal, i a la tarda surto.
No he editat res, tu.
Mireu això.
Què has fet tu amb això?
No he editat res. El que he estat fent...
Mira, un ciclista és aquí.
El que he estat fent ha sigut una migdiada de campionato.
Però bueno, ja està, m'ha cundit.
Són les 7, hora que comença a anar-se'n el sol.
Així que anem a visitar Hiba.
El que us deia, l'hotel aquest té unes banderes a l'entrada,
que, ostres, per molts països,
aquests països serien l'eix del mal, no?
Per començar, Afganistan.
Hi ha la bandera d'Afganistan.
Després, crec que hi ha la de Bielorússia, Turkmenistan,
Índia, Rússia, Xina...
I, per alt, també hi ha la d'Alemanya.
No ho sé, molt bé, perquè...
A veure què tal Hiba.
Una de les millors coses d'Uzbekistan sabeu què és?
Que no hi ha gossos.
Aquí n'hi ha un.
El primer que veig,
des que estic a Uzbekistan.
Clar, és que amb aquesta calor
no es pot sobreviure, home, por els gossos.
No sé massa de Hiba, igual que de tot el país,
però, bueno, pel que he estat investigant aquests dies,
del que valia la pena d'Uzbekistan o no,
hi ha, doncs, quatre ciutats que valen la pena visitar i ja està.
Aquest és un país de visita de ciutats,
que són Tashkent, la capital,
Bokhara, on vaig estar,
Samarkand, que serà l'última part del meu viatge,
i Hiba.
I aquesta és la part,
més oriental de la meva visita
i de la majoria de visites de la gent.
Ara estic bastant... Ostres, tu!
Aquí els carritos de golf, tu, s'honoreixen per moure's.
Van com locos.
Està bastant al mig del país, sí, sí.
Però si t'hi fixes al Google Maps,
aquesta zona, veieu que és verd?
No seria, tampoc, un ambient tropical,
però està a un lloc on deu ser com, no sé,
està com més...
enfonsat, llavors deu haver-hi més humitat,
o el que sigui.
I, bueno, hi ha arbres, com a mínim, saps?
No és un desert absolut, és diferent.
Mira, banderes llegant d'Uzbekistan.
Ja hi ha pocs turistes a la resta del país,
doncs jo crec que aquí encara en veurem menys,
perquè, clar,
necessites tenir bastantes ganes
d'arribar fins aquí tan lluny, eh?
Jo per què he vingut?
Doncs per dos motius.
Un, perquè tinc més temps que la majoria de turistes,
no tinc, allò, una feina que tornar a casa.
I dos, perquè el Matier m'ho va recomanar.
Qui és el Matier?
El Matier és aquell noi francès
que està fent la volta al món corrent.
No ho està compartint per les xarxes socials,
només a l'Estrava.
I us vaig parlar d'ell a Croàcia.
Ei, va adelantat a mi,
d'acord?
Però, clar, jo he agafat un avió,
molts quilòmetres,
i l'he adelantat a ell.
Però, a Uzbekistan.
I demà arriba a Hiba.
I, clar, ell i jo hem estat parlant
de manera, doncs, freqüent
sobre el que ens pot esperar,
el que...
Clar, i anava endavant, no?
Llavors jo li preguntava, escolta,
per aquí què tal?
Ves per aquí, ves per allà, saps?
I ell em recomanava, vam parlar dels gossos,
que hi va tenir un problema molt gran.
I va tenir un problema molt gran
a Macedònia, que...
Bueno, quasi el maten
una manada de 6 gossos salvatges.
Bueno, al final no li va passar res, eh?
Total, ostres, vam dir, home,
ja que estem aquí els dos en aquest país,
ens hem de trobar, i sí, sí,
doncs, he vingut aquí especialment
per demà quedar amb ell
i demà per la tarda arriba.
Llavors, perfecte, coincideix, perfecte.
Bueno, més xerrameca, més bones notícies.
Avui és dilluns, i per tant, avui,
avui, doncs, tornaven a funcionar les oficines,
i us en recordeu del visat de Tajikistan?
Ja el tinc.
Vaig pagar 190 euros
a una persona que no conec,
que hi havia algunes ressenyes a Google,
a TripAdvisor, però què,
jo no sabia si era una persona que de veritat
existia i
m'anava a fer el tràmit del visat a Tajikistan.
I sí, sí, avui m'ha dit,
mira, ja el tinc, i m'ha enviat,
no us el posaré, vale, perquè és un document personal,
però sí, sí, ja tinc el visat.
Alguns m'ho ha dit, Enric, però si
per entrar a Tajikistan no n'has dit el visat.
Això és cert, però
l'entrada només per 30 dies.
A Tajikistan jo calculo que seran uns
1.100 quilòmetres.
Amb 30 dies seria possible?
Sí, però seria
molt, molt just. Jo crec
que no necessito ni 50,
jo crec que amb 30 i pico, 40
em faria, però just 30
és molt, molt, molt just.
I no vull anar patint.
Llavors, el visat aquest que he fet,
doncs, són 60 dies,
i, bueno,
m'ha costat 190 euros, us ho torno a repetir,
i tal. Però ja el tinc, ja el tinc.
Llavors, a veure, el pla serà
dos nits aquí a Hiba,
dimecres vaig a Samarkand,
estaré dos nits més,
i divendres
començo a caminar, ja per fi,
començo a caminar
per Asia Central. I de Samarkand
a la frontera amb Tajikistan
només hi ha 40 quilòmetres, per tant,
a Uzbekistan caminaré molts pocs quilòmetres.
Estan plantant aquí flors, tu,
aquí al costat
de la carretera, amb aquesta calor,
deuen ser flors especials que aguanten, no?
He de dir que aquí fa un pèl menys de calor
que a Bokhara, cosa que jo no entenc.
Bé, deu ser aquest microclima que us he dit
que està una mica enfonsat
i és més verd, no? A Bokhara feia
màxima de 40,
i aquí 36.
Uh! Vinga, ja tenim
aquí les muralles de la ciutat.
Noto que el color és diferent, és turquès
aquí, no? Bueno, o més verd,
verd tipus mar,
no? No és blau com a
Bokhara.
Bokhara o Bokhara, no sé com es diu.
Són llocs aquests màgics, eh? Mira,
Bokhara no tenia la...
la d'això, la muralla aquesta
que entraves i de cop i volta estàs a un altre món, eh?
Buah, és que et sents
en... No sé,
no sé com explicar, però...
Sents que viatges a una altra època,
encara que són reconstruccions, no?, totes aquestes
ciutats. Però
jo crec que algun dia van ser semblants a això.
M'agradaria pensar que sí, que van ser-ho.
Mira, mira, és que ara estic pujant aquí
per la ciutat. Ah, mira, mira,
mira! Veieu?
Les muralles estan fetes de pedra.
No, pedra no, sorra, perdó.
Vull dir sorra, vull dir fang.
Fang amb palla, no?
Jo crec que això
és a l'exterior, eh? Per l'interior deu ser
amb mètodes
moderns de construcció, eh?, amb formigó.
Ah, ja està. Ah, mira, es pot pujar
per aquí o no? No.
Aquestes escales no van enlloc, arriben aquí i ja està.
Per allà, per allà. Per allà
sí que van. Ah, doncs anem a pujar a la muralla, tu.
Si això estigués fet
de veritat de...
de fang seria bastant... Seria bastant
èpic, eh? Ah, doncs tampoc.
Tampoc. Doncs no sé com es puja aquí.
Potser forma part d'un tour, això.
Ho veieu, no?
Tothom està aquí dalt, a les muralles,
i jo estic aquí, a aquest pis inferior.
Bueno, ja ho trobarem.
Vale, sí que s'havia de pagar.
Sí que s'havia de pagar. Ostres, quines escales, tu.
40.000
m'ha costat, que això són
menys de 4 euros, uns 3 euros.
Vale, està bé. Aquí tot
és barat, per nosaltres.
Ah, s'ha de veure el
Sunset Gate, i des de les
muralles sembla bastant èpic. És un riu
diferent, no?, a Bokhara.
Per una part tenim
aquests edificis, que l'arquitectura és similar,
no?, amb aquests pòrtics, que és molt típic d'aquesta
zona, però per l'altra banda aquestes
muralles i tot aquest rotllo sembla...
africà?
No ho sé.
Ara estic tirant de...
de memòria fotogràfica de
coses que he vist per internet, eh?
Sí, és com més...
No sé, més...
altres... altres llocs.
Sembla diferent, sembla diferent a Bokhara.
Doncs aquí
s'acaben les muralles, tu.
Just que ara venia la millor
part, eh? Mireu aquest edifici
d'aquest color, com us dic, una mica més verdós
aquí, a Hiva.
Increïble, eh? Els colors
d'aquestes
rajoles i
les cúpules...
Els colors que té aquesta
hora del dia, a la posta de sol...
És increïble, eh?
L'Uzbekistan
és increïble.
És que és...
brutal.
M'encanta, m'encanta.
Molt maco, el que veig.
Les cases també
tenen el mateix rotllo
de...
fang i tal,
com venim restaurades així.
Aquestes ciutats tenen dos
cares. La de dia
i la de nit.
I val la pena veure les dues, perquè
normalment les il·luminen així
guais i...
i tal. Aquí tenim
això, que no sé què és, però
mola molt.
Super chill, tu. No, no... Hi ha turistes, eh? Però
no gaires. Per cert, la majoria... Mira,
la majoria de turistes són italians.
I tant a Bokhara
com aquí m'estic trobant molts italians.
No els he dit res. Sóc una mica antisocial.
Mira, aquí tenim
que el govern xinès
va ajudar a restaurar
alguns llocs històrics
de Bokhara. Molt bé, doncs...
Amics, amigos para siempre.
Aquesta és una de les places precioses
que hi ha. Aquí hi ha un restaurant que
posa terrassa.
Mireu, aquí
hi ha uns forns, que suposo que aquests
ja no es fan servir, però són d'estil
tandoori.
També n'hi ha a Georgia, bueno, i a molts
altres països d'aquesta zona.
Tandoori sonarà més a l'Índia.
I el que passa és que aquí es calenta, es fa molt...
es fica molt calent, i el pa es posa
enganxat cap per baix dintre les parets.
I llavors, bueno,
queda el pa, i bueno, doncs,
l'agricultura i tal ho fa amb la seva forma
en concret, no? Però és bastant
típic de diverses zones. A mi em flipa
el fet que puguis fer un pa cap
per baix, però...
Sí, sí. Queda bo, com a mínim el de Georgia
queda bo. El d'aquí no sé si l'he provat.
És brutal. La sensació
és d'estar al decorat d'una
pel·lícula.
És que mai havia vist res així
tan diferent. És que sembla un altre món.
Sembla un altre món.
Alguns en direu, sí, sí,
però clar, és que és un decorat d'una pel·lícula,
perquè és una restauració.
És igual, és igual.
És molt maco,
molt maco. Crec que saps
que és el que m'agrada i el que ens agrada
a molts i el que ens crida l'atenció?
Aquests colors blaus
i turquesa. Crec que és això, eh?
Perquè no són tan habituals en monuments
així antics.
I a les nostres esglésies i nostres
monuments no hi ha coses de color blau.
I a les nostres esglésies i nostres monuments no hi ha coses de color blau.
És una llàstima que no camini per
Uzbekistan. A veure, no tot
és així, eh? Evidentment. Però és una
llàstima perquè hi ha coses que no
veuré com camells.
Sí, hi ha camells
enmig del nord, eh? Enmig del desert. Jo com a mínim ho he vist
en altres aventurers
i moleria, catxo, haver-se trobat un camell.
Malauradament no passarà.
És que fa massa calor. És que seria
massa brutal. Jo demà li vull preguntar
al matí com ho fa.
Com ho fa perquè és
un superhome aquest senyor. Ara estic fora
de les muralles. Després tornaré a entrar per
veure com és de nit tot il·luminat.
Com he dinat
al restaurant, ara faré una mica de street food aquí
que hi ha una espècie de food truck.
A veure què tenen. Doncs ha tocat
un hot dog amb patates fregides,
una fanta i la muralla
del fons aquí il·luminada.
Una passada. Dos euros
i pico. Molt bé tu.
Li he dit, ui, de quin animal
és el hot dog?
I diu, de pollastre.
I dic, ah, vale, al meu país són de porc.
Diu, ui, porc? És haram.
Que vol dir pecat.
Jo és que sóc haram, sóc pecat.
El que us dic, eh,
de nit és una altra història.
És que
és flipant, eh. Està molt ben il·luminat.
És superxulo.
Millor que a Bokhara, eh.
A Bokhara, per la nit, l'il·luminació
tenia un punt, bé, amb poc gust.
Però, molt bé.
Hello.
És flipant, també,
l'amplitud tèrmica. És a dir,
a les tres de la tarda, et mors.
No pots estar pel carrer. Et mors, literalment.
O sigui, jo, hi havia moments que em marejava.
I, en canvi,
ara, s'està de luxe.
Però de luxe, de luxe. És a dir,
a Barcelona hi hauria moltíssima humitat, però com aquí
el clima és molt sec, doncs,
ara estem a vint i pico i això està
genial, genial. Per la tarda, jo diria
que la meitat de gent que veies
per aquí, per la ciutat antiga, eren
guiris. I ara, per la nit,
guiris som un 10% o menys, eh.
Tots són locals
que estan passejant per aquí.
Molt bé, m'he comprat un gelat.
Vaig a fer una volta llarga
i tranquil·la del xil,
perquè s'està molt xil, s'està molt tranquil.
I ens veiem demà.
Fins demà.
Tenir això drets d'autor, que et flipes.
Hi ha una espècie de gris,
no?, en què hi ha uns nois que
es posen davant de les noies i es fan
una mica així, els xulos.
Porta uns vestits, té un rotllo flamenco, eh,
també.
Això és genial, tio.
Això és increïble, tu.
Com passen aquestes coses
que et trobes coses així sense
esperar, és brutal.
Això és junts fora de les muralles.
Sort que m'ha donat per sortir per l'altra banda.
Això està molt coordinat, eh.
Aquí hi ha setmanes
i mesos d'entrenament, eh.
Estic flipant.
Estic flipant en colors.
Estaven fent els baixs aquests.
Tothom super animat.
Música molt alegre.
I de cop i volta...
No sé, l'escolto.
De cop i volta han parat tots.
Han parat de ballar.
Segurs?
Molt, molt loco això.
I s'ha acabat la pregària i tornen a ballar.
Xocs culturals. Això sí que és...
Mira, et podria dir que seria el xoc cultural
més gran de tot el viatge, eh, de moment.
Passen moltes coses. Ah, no sé què està passant.
Hi ha una espècie d'invasió de camp.
Totes les dones del meu costat s'han aixecat
i han anat cap a l'escenari.
No sé què passarà. És molt divertit això.
Caos.
Caos. Ara se'n va tothom.
No sé què passa.
I en comptes de venir aquí a l'escenari un altre cop a mirar
se'n van. No entenc res.
M'encanta.
Ha fugit tothom en desbandada
i aquí a l'escenari queden quatre
i les ballarines fan com...
assajant, ballant sense música.
No ho entenc.
I'm out. Ara sí. Ara sí.
Vaig cap a l'hotel.
La volta al món a peu.
Dia 248.
Torno a Correus.
Torno a Correus per dos motius. Un, he d'enviar encara...
setze postals que em faltaven.
I dos, us en recordeu a Turquia?
Que vaig deixar el meu número de telèfon
i em van trucar perquè quedaven per pagar crec que
dues postals.
Doncs per evitar que això passés
i deixessin d'enviar postals els hi vaig dir
ei, us deixo el meu número per si de cas.
I m'han trucat aquest matí.
M'apel·laven en anglès però m'han dit posta, posta.
Jo, vale, vale. Ara vaig.
A veure què volen. Espero que sigui només per pagar postals
que m'hagin descomptat.
N'havia deixat de pagar
47.
Jo vaig fer piles de 50
i vaig sumar malament, suposo.
47 postals.
Bueno, el fet de deixar el número de telèfon suposo que
ja es veia que no anava de mala fe, no?
Les he pagat i ja està.
Bueno, anem a visitar una mica més
jiba.
Algun museu
o alguna cosa que es pugui entrar fins que
arribi l'hora de més calor perquè
ja són les deu o així.
.
Bueno, aquest ticket ja no ha sigut tan barat, eh?
18 euros.
Però em dóna accés a tot això.
Tots els museus
i mesquites i edificis de la ciutat
excepte les muralles que van anar
a part que les vam visitar ahir.
Bueno, tu, doncs, tinc feina, eh?
Tinc feina. Bueno, anem al primer que seria
el...
Kasihana.
Bueno, hem començat forts, eh?
Aquest petit museu
ensenyava antics càstigs
de l'època dels emirs, com per exemple
enterrar viu el delinqüent,
empalar-lo,
apadrejar-lo,
tirar-lo del minaret, i una cosa
que posava woman punish,
castig per dones,
i surt una dona dintre un sac amb serps.
Espero que de resta siguin
més amables.
No us ensenyaré tot, només les parts més interessants.
Mireu aquest lloc, tu,
amb les rajoles blaves, aquestes columnes
de fusta amb aquests gravats.
Brutal, eh?
És brutal.
Em pregunto si això és mantingut en el temps
o restaurat. Perquè molt
d'això està restaurat.
Bueno, suposo que van mantenir
una mica l'estètica
de l'època, no? Sí, sí.
Sí, sí.
Sí.
Fins demà!
A veure si el trobo, he buscat el nom del plat al Google Maps
i em sortia un restaurant, no sé si això és un restaurant, però està per aquí, a veure.
Doncs el plat en qüestió és aquest, xivit oxi.
Són uns fideus que fan a mà i abans de començar a amassar-los els hi posen moltes herbes,
llavors per això tenen aquest color verd,
i per sobre té un estofat de vedella i salsa de iogurt.
Llavors li dona un sabor que és com molt fresc, molt bé per l'estiu.
Molt bo, eh?
Molt bo, l'he acompanyat amb aquesta amanida de tomàquet, que aquí les fan molt bé.
Els fideus estan molt suaus, molt tubets, són els típics fideus de sèmola, tal.
A mi m'agrada, eh? A mi no m'agrada anar a la pasta al dente.
Molt bo, eh? Molt, molt, molt bo.
Hola! Hola.
Les 8 i 12, ha estat descansant aquesta tarda, el matí ell està aquí, està amb un col·lega.
Li anava a preguntar a veure quants quilòmetres ha corregut avui.
How many did you do today?
Forty... two.
Not too bad, you will have to tell me how you do it with this hat.
You will have to tell me how you do it with this hat, with this kit.
But let's go to drink a beer first.
Bueno, ja estem aquí.
Li he fet una entrevista al Matiè, que podreu veure al proper vídeo.
I ara he vingut aquí a un lloc que té, bueno, un senyor amb un clarinet tocant i unes vistes brutals.
També amb preus, doncs, més brutals i més normals.
Hi ha gent que em mira, no sé si són catalans.
I, doncs, ara farem un brindis.
Cin cin? Cin cin?
I res, fins al proper vídeo, ja a Samarkand!